si vous avez un smartphone de Samsung et
un tout nouveau widget météo dynamique
vachement cool qui vient d'arriver
regardez je vous le montre vous venez
sur votre Smartphone vous faites un
appui long et vous allez dans widget
vous allez choisir météo juste là là
vous aviez de la météo classique en deux
par deux là vous avez de la météo
dynamique et ça c'est vachement mieux
vous cliquez dessus vous l'ajoutez et la
regarder c'est dynamiques c'est beau
c'est sympa c'est fluide je trouve ça
vachement mieux que d'avoir de la météo
un peu plus classique un peu plus triste
un peu plus standard regardez je mets
les deux côte à côte ça n'a rien à voir
il y a pas photo c'est qu'à de le dire
la dynamique est quand même vachement
mieux je sais pas laquelle vous préférez
contrôler deux marques le moi dans les
commentaires et puis est-ce que vous
connaissez cette astuce oui non quoi
comment marquer le moi également dans
les commentaires